so is star trek strange new worlds a
really good show that can never become a
great show
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so i've just finished watching star trek
strange new worlds and i've really
enjoyed it out of all the new trek it's
by far the best
it's a really really good show
but can it ever be a great show
the problem is for me
a good show that become a great show
needs to have a great protagonist there
needs to be a really good bad guy
and the problem with strange new worlds
is they can't really do that because
it's a prequel
we know what happens and it's not just a
prequel it's a prequel that's going to
get very very close to the original
series time frame so sometimes you can
do a prequel and if it goes you know 100
years 200 years 300 years into the past
you can do something you can cr you know
you can create a bad guy that maybe we
wouldn't know about from the original
series but in this one it's too close so
we know what happens and that's the
problem we know what happens
in strange new worlds the romulans the
klingons yes but we know what happens to
those story lines so in the first series
of strange new worlds they've gone with
the gorn and they created them as the
bad guy and they've created some
brilliant episodes but at the end of the
day this is a villain that we know about
and we know don't become a threat long
term
in discovery they got around this by
just changing time and then making
everybody not talk about it
but that was kind of stupid and we
definitely can't do it again
so how does strange new worlds go from
being a good show with brilliant
characters to becoming a great show
i honestly don't see how it can it's
going to be a very character-driven
series obviously
and it's going to be
a lot of fun
but it can never be the great show we
really really deserve and want after
some of the not so great stuff star trek
has done in the last couple of years
my other worry about strange new worlds
is
james t kirk coming into the series next
season how are they going to manage that
and are we going to bleed into actually
just an original series reboot
if they do that i think it will annoy a
lot of hardcore fans and anything that
messes with canon is never particularly
popular
but anyway that's just a quick video
with my thoughts on strange new worlds a
show that i have thoroughly enjoyed
but that i worry about where it's gonna
go in the second series
i'd love you guys to make a comment tell
me what you think about strange new
worlds and do you think it can become
the great show we hope it can
please get in the comments tell me
exactly what you think and if you are
new to the channel please like subscribe
hit the bell notification really helps
out and if you enjoy the content i make
then please consider hitting the join
button that really supports the channel
thanks very much guys and um you know
please stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you